on today's show there will be so much
fire so much fury and frankly power
fiery and power with regard to North
Korea will go through all of the things
having to do with North Korea plus
Ashley John gets very angry when a guy
says that she's a sweetheart well that's
weird I'm Ben Shapiro this is a venture
pyroshow so on Passover Jews do a prayer
in the middle of the Hagaddah where it
talks about the God bringing his wrath
down upon the Egyptians and it says that
God brings the band of emissary of evils
and the hand of God and the finger of
God and and fire and fury and basically
Trump decided that he was gonna quote to
Hagaddah yesterday with regard to North
Korea we'll go through all of that plus
the left seems much more perturbed with
President Trump than they are with Kim
jong-un which is very weird to me and
quasi disgusting that quasi it's just
disgusting we'll get to all of that
actually but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at blind comm
so right now look around your house you
know okay a bunch of ugly curtains or
you have a bunch of blinds that look
like they're from the wire you just you
need to get rid of all the garbage
that's on your windows in order to
replace them you need to go over to
blinds calm and get yourself some really
nice blinds we're not just talking like
that the cheap wire blinds that you see
from the old 80s movies with with with
Nick Nolte we're talking about like
actual blinds that look nice on your
windows and that's what blinds calm does
they make it really easy for you if
you're not sure what you want or even
where to start at blinds calm you get a
free online design consultation you send
them pictures of your house they send
back custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme furniture in specific
rooms I know that I find this
particularly handy because I suck at
this kind of stuff I'm great at
everything else but this is the one
thing in the universe I'm awful at and
that's why blinds calm comes in super
handy they'll even send you free samples
to make sure that everything looks as
good in person as it does online every
order gets free shipping and this is the
best part if you miss measure or you do
it wrong they will fix it they'll remake
your blinds for free so you're the one
who's an idiot and blinds comics are
right anyway and make it really easy for
you there is no excuse for having that
ugly garbage on your windows for a
limited time you get 20% off everything
at blinds comm when you use promo code
bending and that's blinds.com promo code
been as blinds calm promo Clemente
percent off everything this is faux wood
blind cellular shades roller shades and
more blinds calm promo code Ben rules
and restrictions to apply use that
primal code Ben to get your twenty
percent off plus you they will know that
we sent you also by the way just noting
I mean I'm not itself not in any self
aggrandizing we're anything we're still
number two on itunes overall so if you
want to keep us that way we still have
known overcome Oprah and I've decided
that I would very much like to give away
bottles of Vaseline like Tyra Banks and
that crazy YouTube clip but I can't give
them away to all of you but what you can
do is you can go and you can leave us a
review right now and that will help us
overtake Oprah as the number one iTunes
podcast in the United States Oprah must
be defeated Oprah must be defeated like
Cicero talking about Carthage okay Oprah
delenda asked okay we have to have no
pro at the top of the iTunes charts to
go over and subscribe and leave a serve
you okay so now to the news portion of
our show so let's talk about what's
going on with North Korea so over the
last couple of days it's reported that
North Korea Kim jong-un who looks like a
dog chewed tennis ball that got really
pissed at the world kim jong hoon he has
developed apparently a nuclear weapon
that is capable of fitting in a warhead
which can be fitted to his ICBMs
intercontinental ballistic missiles this
of course would give him the capacity to
hit los angeles the bad news about that
is it would end the show the good news
about that is that wipe out hollywood
but it is really not a great thing that
they can hit the united states with
their with their missile technology now
particularly not with a nuke that is
scary stuff and kim jeong-hoon happens
to be one crazy loon bad crazy man so
none of this is good now the president
Trump did something really good over the
weekend he got through the UN Security
Council a 15/0 resolution to place new
sanctions on North Korea that's that's a
good thing even China and Russia voted
for he's also talking about taking
economic measures against China in an
attempt to press them to stop their
material support for the Kim jong-un
regime this seems like a positive move
the respect stored between a rock and a
hard place to be completely honest I
don't have any easy answers on North
Korea because I'm not privy to the
military plan I can tell you what the
general situation is okay
north Korea has 20,000 pieces of
ordnance that are pointed at Seoul Seoul
is a city of millions of people you
could easily see a situation in which
the United States launches a military
strike
on Pyongyang and Kim jong-un basically
pulls a string and suddenly Seoul 100
200,000 people are dead in the middle of
the capital of South Korea I means that
close so that obviously is weighing
heavily on the minds of the people in
national security positions you know you
sort of hope that they have better plans
than that you sort of hope that they
have the capacity to take out all of
that ordnance as part of a first strike
that if we were going to take out this
this regime that we would take out all
that ordnance at the same time so that
South Korea could live and be well we've
also worked on the installation of the
THAAD missile defense system in South
Korea you recall that president from
Beata clearly and his administration
said we should withdraw funding for that
we absolutely should not and have not so
that means that that is continued to
develop which is a necessary thing so
the the North Koreans developed this new
weapon they are now talking about having
a long-range missile once they have that
makes it very difficult for the United
States to take a preemptive strike
because what happens it has in their
death throes the North Koreans fire off
their ICBM with the new katachi to the
top of it at Los Angeles that's that's
the problem with them having a nuke
another reason why the Iranian deal is
so stupid because the last thing you
want is the Iranians to have the
capacity to deter any military action by
the United States if we feel the
necessity to take some but Trump comes
out yesterday he's asked about this and
he proceeds to basically speak and
actually sort of Kim jong-un type
language with regard to what we are
going to do to North Korea if they
continue to make threats here's what he
had to say North Korea
that's not make anymore threats to the
United States they will be met with fire
and fury like the world has never seen
he has been very threatening beyond a
normal state and as I said they will be
met with fire fury and frankly power the
likes of which this world has never seen
before thank you so everybody took that
at him basically making a threat that
he's going to new clean orth Korea and
that's because of this phrase that he
ends at the end there with you know he
could end with we're going to meet them
with fire and fury and emissary of Eva
and a band of demons and
we are going to unleash of the power
paper out of it ready could have said
that but when he says beyond anything
we've ever seen that makes it sound like
he's actually gonna I mean look at Tom
prices face here it's actually Stefan's
like like Trump wants to nuke North
Korea and a lot of people are freaked
out about that because Trump is
unpredictable he doesn't know much about
nuclear power I mean he didn't know what
the nuclear triad was in the middle of
the campaign so people are freaked out
about that now I don't take it that
seriously I don't think Trump is talking
about nuking North Korea and starting
some sort of nuclear world war 3 with
North Korea he uses that phrase all the
time right when he says more than
anything we've ever seen before like he
says that with regard to his election
victory he said that with regard to
congressional malfeasance he said that
with regard to Obama care and this
language of anything we've ever seen
before it's just like a throwaway line
that he likes to use at the end of
things I tweeted yesterday one of the
problems with the president who speaks
only in superlatives is you actually
don't know when he's serious if you
constantly are saying everything is the
best everything is the grandest like my
grandfather was like this very
enthusiastic guy my grandpa and pop I
used to say everything was the most
exciting everything was the best
everything was the most incredible and
so you never knew whether something was
actually great or whether he had just
gotten like a scoop of ice cream like he
didn't know what the what exactly was
happening the same thing is true of
Trump he speaks constantly in
superlatives and so do you know what
he's talking about the answer is really
not so much now is that a huge deal not
really I mean the fact is that you know
everybody's going nuts over this you
know people are zero he's going to start
World War three no he's not gonna start
World War three and the situation in
North Korea is not Trump's fault the
media is already attempting to place
blame at Trump's feet for the situation
in North Korea obviously that's not true
I'm gonna go through the history of
American malfeasance with regard to
North Korea Trump's been on the job like
five minutes okay this is not Donald
Trump's fault in any real way I do want
to show you this meme that a pro Trumper
was tweeted at me yesterday and I just
thought this is hilarious this is from
the last episode of Game of Thrones in
case you can't see it and it's Kim Jong
Kook sitting near Jaime Lannister
best not make any more threats to the
United States
they will be met with fire and fury like
the world has never seen riding the
dragon into battle Wow Kim jong-un fits
better looking confused so that is
pretty spectacular and of course it's
true that if we were to get into some
sort of actual firefight with North
Korea this sucker is over in five
minutes I mean the United States took
out the third-largest military on planet
Earth and Iraq in three weeks you know
yes it broke out into an insurgency
afterward but if we're just talking
about destroying top-down the
administration in North Korea we could
do that in under 15 minutes
sebastien Gorkhas oh I think it's in I I
think he's really been wrongly maligned
by a lot of people he's a national
security adviser to President Trump
who's on Sean Hannity show last night
Nathan listen North Korea is a lot of
bluster and a lot of talk led by a short
fat dwarf but but we should really but
we should really know that this is a
very very weak country is that enough to
stop this madman or the even Matt he's
just again he likes to cause trouble on
the world stage this is not the Cold War
remember during the Cold War we had this
phrase correlation of forces we had a
balance we had a standoff more than
20,000 nuclear warheads on either side
this is not the Soviet Union this is a
Potemkin village this this regime cannot
even feed its own people that's how much
of a of a paper tiger it is so now they
have to send a very clear message Rex
Tillerson today at the ASEAN meeting
said they can send a signal no more
ballistic missile testing then we will
know that sanity reigns and they don't
want to bring down the ire of the
president and the Western community
against North Korea okay so he's
obviously correct but the problem is
what sort of threat can you actually
leverage against North Korea that's
credible this is the only problem with
Trump's language because Trump says
things and then there's no real
follow-through you don't know what to
take seriously it actually emboldened
our enemies in certain ways so for
example you see that clip he says if
they make any more threats fire fury
dragon fire you know what's the word
that she says when she launches the
dragon fire
any case you know it's that right that's
what Trump is saying and the problem is
that North Korea immediately comes out
and immediately says well okay fine
we're going to sink Guam right this
guy's rivet they came out he said okay
well we'll fire a missile at Guam
okay well that's another threat and the
United States didn't really have any
retaliation for that apparently we're
going to send some missile defense over
to Guam but here's the truth everybody
is overheated about all of this so the
left is super overheated about all of
the CNN says we're all going to die this
this tiny you know stupid country led by
you know it's the country's fine but the
stupid guy who evil piece of garbage who
leads the country he's going to nuke us
all we're all going to die because he
finally has fitted a nuclear warhead to
an ICBM even though we don't know the
ICBM works we don't know if the warhead
works and this guy is basically
relegated to getting bad haircuts and
killing his relatives in airports with
anthrax here is CNN losing its mind
right basically doing the 1950's tile
everybody get under your desk because
we're all going to have to prep Duck and
Cover for the nuclear attack this
picture purports to show Kim jong-un
with a miniaturized nuclear weapon
people lasted it when I came out last
year but now if they believe this is the
real deal what does it show us well it
would suggest that this would be about
two feet across experts say it might
weigh 500 600 pounds something like that
and it would have potentially the
destructive potential of those bombs
that you mentioned which the United
States dropped on Japan seventy two
years ago this week but look at the
difference in size each of these was 10
to 11 feet long weighed around something
on 10,000 pounds these had to be carried
by a heavy bomber this is a different
thing all together in this case maybe
you are talking about something that can
fit in the nose cone of one of their
existing missiles if that is the case it
changes the game because their last
missile test went 2300 miles up into
space way above the space station way
above many satellites out there yeah it
only went 621 land miles but that's
because it basically went straight up
and came straight down some scientists
say if you flatten out that trajectory
if you fire it across the earth then you
could reach Guam you could reach Hawaii
Alaska
some scientists say based on the weight
of the payload in theory they could
reach about half of the United States
and some major cities in here okay so
we're all going to die everybody be
scared now listen is it fine for CNN to
show us what North Korea's capacity is
sure but they kind of scare tactics that
they're using are just ridiculous okay
there's a Fareed Zakaria of CNN he comes
out and he says the real threat here is
Donald Trump and here's here's where the
left really loses their mind okay I'm
going to go through the history of the
North Korean situation and show you why
this is not Trump's fault but the left
is basically saying if anything bad here
happens it's obviously because of Trump
we had blamed Bush and then we had eight
years of Obama existing and we don't
care about about what Obama did because
basically his entire tenure goes into a
black hole according to the media it was
just sunshine and rainbows for eight
years but now Trump is president again
and whatever Trump does has to be wrong
so here's read Zakaria saying it's just
terrible what Trump said about that that
crazy little nutjob Kim jong-un what
worried me about it is the kind of
rhetoric Donald Trump views is the kind
of rhetoric the North Koreans use it's
not the kind of rhetoric the United
States of America uses we are measured
we are careful we match our words with
deeds we do not go out and say that the
you know didn't make these kind of
outlandish claims which finally will not
be met we will not let me confidently
say respond to North Korea with fire and
fury the kind of which the world has
never seen before okay so it's so
terrible how could general Trump uses
language direct quote Bill Clinton 1993
it would mean the end of their country
as they know it it's Bill Clinton who
said that about North Korea if they were
to use a nuclear weapon would mean the
end of their country as they know it
okay so apparently you know it's the end
of the world if Trump uses this sort of
language well and Oakland use that sort
of language no problem at all another
MSNBC analyst says the same thing with
Trump he's just like a North Korean
leader I mean it's just like that and I
make a joke about the sort of language
that he uses but they actually take that
seriously the president sounds like a
North Korean leader Kim jong-il Kim
jong-un you know the son of Kim jong-il
Kim jong-il they all talked about
literally see a fire that was the the
threat
they used more often than not I have a
huge file folder of all the crazy
colorful things that the North Korean
would say and the names that they would
call our American presidents so
president Trump sounds more like a North
Korean leader unfortunately than an
American leader okay
again no not so much is the language
overblown of course civil because that
too Trump is do I wish that General
James Madison were in charge of all of
our military policy yeah I do but I
would be much more comfortable sleeping
at night if it were mattis we're making
these sorts of comments right mattis
does say this sort of stuff and you have
to take it seriously when Trump says it
you know he could be talking about
contestants on The Apprentice you just
don't know but is this the you know the
left is so intent on making Trump the
bad guy that they're forgetting that
Trump actually hasn't done anything
wrong here and what he's talking about
is perfectly within the realm of
possibility no he's not talking about
nuclear weapons used Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson said that this morning
again is one of the problems with Trump
and Twitter is he went on Twitter and
then he said well we've modernized our
nuclear weapons so in case we have to
use them but in real in reality the
White House is not seriously talking
about any of that now I want to get to
the the history of the North Korean
situation in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over a blue apron so everyone in LA has
blue apron everyone in LA is lazy we
don't like going to the grocery store we
don't know how to shop for things we
certainly don't know how to cook but
that's where blue apron comes in so a
blue apron does is they send you all of
the freshest ingredients with the recipe
and it comes to your house and you cook
it yourself it is fresh it is
home-cooked it tastes restaurant quality
I mean they send you all of these meals
and it's under $10 per person for any
delicious meal that they send you
different meals every day they don't
repeat meals so you never get bored you
know for us at our house we have the
same meals like ever to Monday
but with blue apron you don't have to
you know fact is the blue apron will
switch the recipes I mean listen to some
of these recipes basil pesto chicken
with summer vegetable Potenza Noah I
know what panzanella is and it sounds
amazing whole-grain pasta and summer
vegetables with the heirloom tomato
caprese salad meatball pizza with fresh
mozzarella cheese in terms Manos I can't
eat that because of the meat milk but
you can if you're not Jewish so enjoy
yourself because that sounds amazing all
the sounds terrific there are certain
things in Judaism that you really you
know that you you envy those who don't
actually have to keep the law of meat
and milk sounds terrific together but we
don't do that but if you're with blue
apron and you don't keep kosher
then it's all
you man because it's going to be amazing
everybody people in the office of used
blue apron they love blue and everyone
in LA is using it right now in the you
know blue apron calm slash Shapiro blue
apron calm slash up hero you get your
first three meals free with free
shipping if you go to blue apron comm
slash appear oh you'll love how good it
feels and taste to create incredible
home-cooked meals much less expensive
than going to a restaurant much cleaner
much better much fresher blue apron calm
slash Shapiro less than $10 per person
per meal and right now you get your
first three meals free with free
shipping at blue apron comm slash
Shapiro blue apron is a better way to
cook blue apron comm slash Shapiro and
that lets them know that we sent you as
well okay so when just a final note on
the left losing its mind over Trump
MSNBC's lawrence O'Donnell who is just
an egregiously bad host he came out and
he said the big problem here is that
both North Korea and the United States
have unpredictable wires in charge right
it's the same leadership is in North
Korea in the United States come on now
come on his response to that uniquely
bad news for his uniquely incompetent
and ineffective administration is to
simply lie and to say that his
administration has achieved more than
most a North Korean regime style lie
that's Donald Trump's choice to in terms
of describing the accomplishments of his
administration and so the Trump
administration enters its first deadly
serious dangerous international crisis
this time with an unpredictable liar in
North Korea and for the first time in
American history the United States as an
unpredictable liar who is in control of
the nuclear codes that could instantly
create fire and fury like the world has
never seen
there is no indication that the White
House or the president had any intention
at all of making any comment about North
Korea today what the President did say
was in response to a shouted question by
a reporter okay so it's just terrible
that everything the Trump does is wrong
everything Trump does his dad Trump is
the real threat you know this is a
constant refrain from the weapon is
getting very irritating the United
States is always the real threat George
HW Bush was a cowboy war monger he was
the real threat in the Middle East
Israel is the real threat in Europe it's
the Europeans who are the real threat
it's always the West that's the real
threat a trump is the real threat Obama
was never the real threat because he was
of the left but anybody who is not
hardcore left is part of the problem you
see it's not just kim jeong-hoon is an
evil dictator who's enslaved millions of
people inside of his own country
starved our people do you understand
that the average height of a North
Korean is I believe three inches shorter
than the average height of a South
Korean there's the same genetic stock so
why is that it's because malnutrition in
North Korea is a giant garbage if you
look at the satellite photos you see at
night North South Korea completely lit
up you get to North Korea nothing
completely black there are no lights
anywhere in North Korea except Kim Jong
Un's little palace so it's just a but
don't worry it's not all Trump who's the
real threat this is one of the things
that Madden's me about the left because
the fact is that even if you're of the
left you could acknowledge that in times
of national crisis like this in times
when you have an evil dictator
threatening the United States maybe you
ought to give the president a little bit
more credit than to compare him to the
evil dictator in a serious way maybe you
ought to give him a little more credit
because the fact is the United States is
still the United States when Barack
Obama did something I disagreed with
when he went into Libya
you know I disagreed with that I thought
it was a bad move by President Obama to
get rid of Muammar Qaddafi I never
compared Obama to Qaddafi I never
thought they were the same person that's
insane okay to try and compare the
American leader to dictators foreign
dictators and suggest that they are of
the same piece is really just a way of
blaming America for problems around the
world with which it had nothing to do
now the other thing that's happened here
is that there's been this attempt to
read Trump back into history
oh it's Trump's fault if everything
falls apart its Trump's fault
Trump has inherited a 50 to say well
really a 60 year bad situation I don't
go all the way back we're gonna go back
into the time machine and talk about the
US policy with regard to North Korea
because it's always been pretty
egregiously bad so we fight the Korean
War the Korean War starts almost right
after World War two when the Chinese and
the North Koreans begin to invade South
Korea and and then Harry Truman says we
have to check that advance and he sends
MacArthur to basically stop that here is
Harry Truman talking at the time about
why the United States has an interest in
in retaining the freedom of South
if the Soviet Union really want peace it
can prove it and could have proved it on
any day since last June 25th by joining
the rest of the United Nations and
calling upon the North Koreans to lay
down their arms at once
okay so Harry Truman called on the
Russians to stop supporting the North
Koreans and the Chinese to stop
supporting the North Koreans it never
happened and then the Chinese started
pouring people across the border
MacArthur suggested let's strike China
and get this over with right away and
Harry Truman said no we're not going to
do that and ended up firing MacArthur
North Korea survives South Korea ends up
surviving through the sacrifice of
50,000 American troops we lost an
enormous number of men in South Korea
attempting to defend a free South Korea
and thank God we didn't because South
Korea's a flourishing Western country
today it would be another communist
dictatorship hellhole at the word for
the sacrifice of America's brave men in
the armed services during the Korean War
the Forgotten war in American history a
good war that we fought and retained
freedom for millions of people who now
live under the threat of a nuclear-armed
dictator in North Korea I want to
continue with our little history lesson
because this is not about Trump okay
this is about the West that made the
wrong move at every step in the North
Korean history but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at stamps
comm so in sick of waiting in line at
the post office you forgot to go to the
grocery store and pick up stamps well no
fear you're sitting at your computer
right now maybe listening to this
podcast and you need stamps for all your
outgoing mail you need to go over to
stamps calm right now they bring all the
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips you can buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer they make it easy
they even send you a digital scale
automatically calculating the exact
postage I use stamps calm because I am
sick of waiting at the post office and I
don't want my employees having to run
over to the post office and waste time
in line so go to stamps calm click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro that stamps
comm enter promo code Shapiro and right
now you will get a four week trial plus
postage and the digital scale without
any long-term commitment go to stamps
comm click on the microphone at the top
of the page type in Shapiro and that
will get you that free week trial plus
postage plus digital scale no long term
commitment again that stamps.com promo
code Shapiro
never go to the post office again use
that promo code Shapiro's that they know
that we sent you as well okay so Harry
Truman were involved in the in the
Korean War by the end of the Korean War
which ends July 27th 1953 when there's
an armistice sign that creates the
Korean Demilitarized Zone which
separates North Korea from South Korea
the conflict was never actually declared
a war it was always considered a police
action and supposedly to uphold the the
ability of the international community
to control North Korea well so much for
that okay Eisenhower who's the guy who
signed the armistice hears that his
explanation of why the United States was
involved in the Korean War when the
enemy struck on that June day of 1950
what did America do it did what is
always has done in all these times of
peril it appealed to the heroism of its
youth this appeal was utterly right and
utterly inescapable it was inescapable
not only because this was the only way
to defend the idea of collective freedom
against the savage aggression that
appeal was inescapable because there was
now in the plight into which we had
stumbled no other way to save honor and
self-respect the answer to that appeal
has been what any American knew it would
be it has been sheer valor power on all
the Korean mountainsides that each day
they're fresh guards of new graves okay
so when the fact is that the United
States intervention is what allowed us
health Korea to exist but the reality of
Truman's unwillingness to listen to
MacArthur's plans to cross the Yalu
River and actually strike at the Chinese
led both to the continuation of a
Chinese regime which continues to
oppress a billion people today but also
the continuation of the North Korean
regime okay fast forwards and now we go
forward to the Clinton administration so
we've had kim il-sung who is the head of
the the Kim family in North Korea and
he's been succeeded by Kim jong-il who
is the the father of the current kim
jong hoon Kim jong-il was one who gets
made fun of in in Team America if you
recall and he is developing nuclear
weapons and he's developing long-range
missile capabilities and Bill Clinton is
so concerned about this in 1993 that one
of the options that is presented to him
is a deal where he would actually put
10,000 more American troops into South
Korea we would move battle carriers into
the region we'd start evacuating
American citizens from that region in
preparation possibly for strike against
North Korea and that's when Jimmy Carter
goes on CNN without permission of the
Clinton administration goes on CNN and
he announces on CNN that he's come to an
agreement so Jimmy Carter goes
freelancing and creates this framework
for an agreement and then Bill Clinton
goes on TV and takes credit for this
garbage framework
this is 1994 President Bill Clinton
making concessions to an evil terrorist
regime before I take your questions I'd
like to say just a word about the
framework with North Korea that
ambassador Dellucci signed this morning
this is a good deal for the United
States North Korea will freeze and then
dismantle its nuclear program South
Korea and our other allies will be
better protected the entire world will
be safer as we slow the spread of
nuclear weapons South Korea with support
from Japan and other nations will bear
most of the cost of providing North
Korea with fuel to make up to the
nuclear energy it is losing and they
will pay for an alternative power system
for North Korea that will allow them to
produce electricity while making it much
harder for them to produce nuclear
weapons the United States and
international inspectors will carefully
monitor North Korea to make sure it
keeps its commitments only as it does so
will North Korea fully join the
community of nation under of this crap
happened all that happened here was the
United States basically rebuilt North
Korea's electrical grid work we provided
them the material for light nuclear
reactors and they continued to covertly
create a nuclear weapon and the reason
they continue to do that is because
after all what's is just going to keep
capitulating capitulating and
capitulating then the best thing that
you can do is ratchet up the amount of
weaponry that you have in order to
prevent and forestall a military strike
on North Korea okay I want to talk about
more malfeasance from the Clinton
administration than what bush did and
what Obama did but for that you're going
to have to go over to daily wire calm
$4.99 a month you can become a
subscriber to daily wire that means you
can see our audio show in its full
visual glory
it means that you can see the Michal
Knowles show which is brand new and
surging up the iTunes news and politics
charts for some godforsaken reason but
that is that it's filmed at 12:30 today
so you can watch that live at 12:30
today Pacific time you can see the
wonderful and underrated Andrew Clavin
show which also has been making some
serious moves on the iTunes charts you
can check that out that starts at what
10 o'clock 10:00 10:15 here on here at
daily wire you can see all these things
live by subscribing for $9.99 a month
and you'll be part of the mailbag on all
three shows which pretty awesome deal
plus you get to see our wonderful
beautiful glorious website ad free now
if you want to get the annual
subscription then you can get this
magnificent leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr it is filled with the fire and
the fury and frankly the power it's
incredible and you will get this for
free when you get an annual subscription
for just 99 dollars a year to go over
and check it out plus as I said before
we are currently ranked number 2 in
iTunes as we have been all week long
thanks to you our wonderful listenership
if you go over and you haven't done it
yet subscribe leave a review that helps
us defeat Oprah and we must defeat Oprah
The Oprah must be defeated she's
currently number one on iTunes that must
end her reign of terror must end and and
we must bring the fire and the fury to
iTunes so go over there subscribe and
leave us a review we always appreciate
it we are the largest conservative
podcast in the Nature
[Music]
you
so again the media are blaming Trump
their CTO Trump is the one who screwed
everything up with regard to North Korea
okay so we've just shown you how Truman
screwed up North Korea how I signed an
armistice
but that armistice led to the
continuation of North Korea we've shown
you how Bill Clinton screwed up North
Korea and then he screws it up further
so this is really funny it's funny how
the media twist these things I was
watching a documentary I think it was
done by the New York Times about North
Korea and and the nuclear deal that Bill
Clinton did
and what's really hilarious about this
is they try to blame it on Bush so
everything has to be blamed on Bush so
it's it's so Clinton signs this crappy
deal and then they say well
congressional Republicans came in and
undermined the deal no that's not
correct
Bill Clinton continued to fund the deal
he continued to make concessions and
this this ridiculous this ridiculous
lawn gnome
you know kim jeong-hoon he builds a Kim
jong-il his father builds up a missile
program continues to build nuclear arms
and so Bill Clinton deploys Madeline
Albright in the late 90s to go over and
give Kim Jong Kim jong-il a basketball
and make nice with him listen to how
delusional you want to hear is
illusional listen to how delusional
Madeleine Albright be the Secretary of
State under Bill Clinton was about Kim
jong-il at the time I went haven't been
briefed on what kind of a weirdo he was
from our own people he was portrayed as
a reclusive like with many girlfriends
and watching porno movies and basically
a very weird kind of person that you had
no idea what he was going to be like he
was actually quite charming while I knew
all the terrible things that he had done
I could at least make the distinction
that he wasn't crazy he was very very
well prepared responded without notes
was not only respectful but also
interested in what I had to say the
talks with secretary Albright lead to a
remarkable breakthrough Kim Jong Il puts
his missile program on the table he
offers to and all export of ballistic
missiles he offers to freeze the
production deployment and testing of all
ballistic missiles with a range of 300
miles from war okay and so did they
claim here if the Clintons were right on
the verge of a breakthrough and then
Evol George Bush came along and sunk all
of that absolute nonsense Kim Jong Il
was going to continue building these
missiles no matter what because he'd
been doing so for the past 15 years okay
the idea that it was Bush that ruined
everything is just absolute hogwash it
is absolute nonsense okay and then
finally you know the the illrick the Kim
regime begins test-firing nuclear
weapons and missiles in 2003 2004 Bush
declares them part of the axis of evil
and now we fast forward to 2009 you want
to hear some tough talk that means
nothing Barack Obama spent eight years
doing nothing about the burgeoning
missile capabilities of the North
Koreans this is him in 2009 saying don't
worry there's gonna be a lot of
consequences consequences like like
stuff that I say right here from my
mouth with words Barack Obama dealt
North Korea's nuclear and ballistic
missile programs pose a grave threat to
the peace and security the world and I
strongly condemned their reckless action
North Korea's actions endanger the
people of Northeast Asia they are a
blatant violation of international law
and they contradict North Korea's own
prior commitments now the United States
and the international community must
take action in response the record is
clear north Korea has previously
committed to abandoning its nuclear
program instead of following through on
that commitment
it has chosen to ignore that commitment
its actions have also flown in the face
of United Nations resolutions as a
result North Korea is not only deepening
its own isolation it's also inviting
stronger international pressure yeah
clearly that's a revelation again all of
this is nonsense and now here comes from
boneses payer in fury and if one goes oh
my god you're going to kill us all we're
all going to die ah okay the chances
here
are that the North Koreans are just
attempting to dissuade the United States
from doing all of this if we were to
take a pre-emptive military strike if
there was that possibility without
killing hundreds of thousands of South
Koreans it certainly should be on the
table and the fact that the United
States has for so long and nothing for
50 years done nothing about the
burgeoning threat in fact forwarding
their nuclear capacity and then saying
strong things now meaning anything like
one of two things is happening with
Trump here either he means it in which
case that would be more than presidents
for the last five decades of men or he
doesn't mean anything in which case he's
perfectly with in line with Bill Clinton
and Barack Obama but you can't pretend
that he is some sort of complete nutcase
is doing something that is random and
insane and were the real threat is
Donald Trump it's a bunch of leftist
claptrap it's a piece of propaganda that
is not helpful to the situation at all
at all okay so in other news in non
North korea-related news when the big
story of the day is that FBI agents have
raided the Alexandria home of president
Trump's former campaign chairman late
last month is according to the
Washington Post using a search warrant
these documents and other materials
according to people familiar with the
Special Counsel investigation into
Russian meddling in the 2016 election
federal agents appeared a poem Anna
fort's home without advance in in the
without advance warning in the pre-dawn
hours of July 26th the day after he met
voluntarily with the staff of the Senate
Intelligence Committee the search
warrant was wide-ranging FBI agents
working with Special Counsel Muller
departed the home with various records
Jason Maloney a spokesman from Anna fort
confirmed the agents executed a warrant
at one of the political consultants
homes and atmanah fort cooperated with
the search okay so the reason that this
is very important is because if you
actually have a search warrant that
requires you to actually demonstrate to
a judge probable cause that is how you
actually get a search warrant legally
that means probable cause that you think
a crime has been committed the chances
are very good that Paul Manafort is
going to end up on
wrong end of an indictment here and that
in turn is going to be a problem for
Trump because Trump he was Trump's
campaign manager for three months in the
middle of the campaign and Trump is
going to claim that he didn't know
anything the mana fort was doing we
still don't know if the prosecution of
mana fort would have to do with his
activities during the campaign or there
was just him doing illegal stuff outside
the campaign that has yet to be seen but
it's a cloud looming over the Trump
administration and again hard to say
that mana Ford isn't guilty of anything
or that it's a witch hunts of mana for
when it's been clear for years the Paul
mana for is is deeply embedded and
involved with the Russian government I
mean again I told you about this I was I
was approached by somebody back in like
2012 I think now to write columns about
Ukraine and he dropped Paul man afford
to name he had pitched me think one
column about Ukraine without dropping
mana for its name I wrote the column
because I thought it was an interesting
pitch and then he mentioned mana for its
name and I looked into it I was like no
we're not doing any of this anymore
we're not going to do any of these
things and mana Ford has long been a
Kremlin stooge essentially so this would
not be any great shock but it has the
potential to dirty up the Trump campaign
you could certainly see a situation in
which people say Trump's campaign
manager Paul Manafort that he is a that
he was a Russian stooge Trump was
working with him because he was a
Russian stooge you know it's just too
early to say so before we all go off on
the witch-hunt tangent and say that
Muller is exceeding his grasp right here
manna fort Spencer ready for a long time
and this is not a great shock I've said
for months that if anybody in the Trump
campaign was going to come down with
criminal indictments is probably going
to be manna for it and then the question
was going to be what satrom know when
did he know it and what activities was
manna fort engaged in with regard to the
campaign so before the media jumps to
Trump's guilty of everything and before
the right jumps to the Trump is guilty
of nothing routine let's hear the
evidence that's presented I think that's
a reasonable position okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate and then I'll do a short Bible
talk so things I like we've been doing
books about communism so George Orwell's
most famous book about communism is 1984
it's funny the let's keep saying oh it's
not about communism it's about fascism
guys it's about communism George Orwell
also wrote Animal Farm which is clearly
about communism and he wrote what I
think is actually his best book a book
called homage to Catalonia and it is
about how George Orwell himself Lenin
embedded with the communist
groups in the Spanish Civil War and he
gradually realized that he was fighting
on behalf of some bad guys that yes the
fascists were bad but so are the
Communists an homage to Catalonia is all
about his gradual realization that he
was fighting on the side of people who
wanted some pretty evil and egregious
things it's I think his best written
book I really love homage to Catalonia
it's a forgotten classic you go and
check it out at amazon.com it is as The
New Yorker said is probably the best
book on the Spanish Civil War and Orwell
is just a terrific writer I mean
everything more well wrote is worth
reading and this book is like seriously
nobody ever looks at this book and you
should because it's but I think it's
better than 1984 I think it's better
than Animal Farm okay time for some
things that I hate so a couple of things
that I think even Miller I was on TV
last night one of the things I cannot
stand is just the level of Secotan see
of some people in the Trump
administration toward Trump it's just
it's off-putting it's egregious it
demonstrates that this is all the Trump
cares about and that's really gross so
yesterday there was a report that Trump
every morning has delivered to him in a
folder basically a propaganda folder
that has in it news clippings about how
wonderful he is headlines about how
great he is and then also pictures of
himself looking tough on the news
seriously okay that's not good that's
not good okay that's the kind of
narcissism that leads to bad
decision-making and then you have
members of his communication staff going
on TV and seeing how deeply they can
bury their nose in his ass in order to
elevate themselves in Trump's minds
they're performing for an audience of
one Stephen Miller who's a very smart
guy I know Stephen you know Stephen who
is a policy wonk when it comes to
immigration he's done tons of Carlton
last night and he unleashes this
broadside of inanity with regard to
president Trump's myriad qualities
president Trump's the most gifted
politician of our time and he's the best
orator to hold that office in
generations and so we're going to take
the message out to the people because he
said he is the leader of this nationwide
and worldwide populist movement okay
really the greatest order in modern
history really is he he's the greatest
politician of our time amazing stuff
amazing stuff from Stephen Noah in fact
we have a clip of Stephen Miller this
back in the 1950s when Stephen Miller
was defending a guy you see
the army was named Raymond Shaw we have
some clips of him and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders and other members of the Trump
administration talking about this
Raymond Shaw character Raymond Shaw is
the kindest bravest warmest most
wonderful human being out of and out of
my life
Raymond chose the bravest kindest
warmest most wonderful human being I've
ever known in my life
I said Raymond Shaw is the kindest
warmest bravest most wonderful human
being I've ever known in my life this of
course is the doll from The Manchurian
Candidate in that movie these people
have actually been brainwashed in
Manchuria by the Chinese government
because Raymond chow is actually a
Chinese spy that of course is not what
is happening here but really can we cut
out the sick oven see like mr. mr.
president I said I gave you a piece of
advice yesterday it was shut up let your
administration to its job because when
that happens good things happen when
another piece of advice please tell your
comms people they don't have to go on TV
and reenact the first scene from King
Lear where King Lear's daughters go up
before King Lear and just and just kiss
his ass like please just stop it because
it's a bad look it doesn't make you look
any better you think that it helps the
American people it doesn't help the
American people it makes it look like
you are self-absorbed and we don't like
self-absorbed presidents as a general
rule it doesn't end well for them okay
other things that I that I hate today so
Roy Moore is one of the candidates for
Alabama Senate and he is and he ran an
ad slamming what he called the DC flying
machine Roy motors very conservative
candidate and he is running against a
guy named Luther strange Luther strange
the interim senator from Alabama who
filled the slot left by Jeff Sessions
when he became Attorney General of the
United States President Trump yesterday
came out and endorsed Roy Moore's
opponent in this race he endorsed
instead of remor he endorsed Luther
strange the current interim senator who
is very much in bed with Mitch McConnell
Roy Moore is a much better candidate and
and it's it's sad to me that Luther
strange one fortunately does not have
the power to control time in space dr.
strange but it is sad to me the
president Trump endorsed the wrong guy
here is some of Roy Moore's ad this is
the guy who should be in runoff her son
at nella Bama they lied about repealing
Obamacare now Mitch McConnell's DC slime
machine spending millions spreading lies
about
more bearing false witness lie we know
why we all know why Roy Moore's honest
and more zzz's own man more fears God
stands for the Constitution fights for
what is right and believes what we
believe drain the swamp send McConnell a
message send them all a message Roy
Moore Senate my name's Roy Moore and I
approve this message
okay so Trump endorsed not Roy Moore but
Mitch McConnell's hand-picked Luther
strange again bad move into Alabama
whoever wins the Republican nomination
is going to win the seat and and Trump
sided with the establishment is not
trending this one okay final thing that
I hate Ashley Judd is very angry because
apparently she was at the airport and
some dude called her calls her
sweetheart I guess and this is this is
just terrible
no man should never call a woman
sweetheart under any circumstances they
should just call them I guess nasty name
so here's here's Ashley Judd getting
very very upset I'm traveling today and
this is the kind of thing to me that
happens which I categorize as everyday
sexism it's so easy to let it go not to
speak up particularly when it's so easy
for someone to push back and say oh I
was just being polite or something like
that so it's coming through security and
a guy said hey sweetheart and I said I'm
not your sweetheart I am your client so
I was already setting the boundary Oh
God
and then when I was setting about what a
nasty person like somebody says
sweetheart there are two ways to say
sweetheart one's like a sweetheart
elected to meeting okay another is just
say sweetheart like you're just talking
to a person like when an older man talks
to a younger woman that's fairly common
like my dad when he talks to younger
woman when he talks to younger women who
he's being friendly to sometimes he'll
just say he'll say sweetheart just like
a nice thing like my dad is the queen of
guy I know I mean it's just it's insane
for Ashley Jenn to get like there's so
many things to be offended over in the
world there's so many things to be angry
over in the world somebody calling you
sweetheart we're holding a door open for
you is not the thing to be offended over
if this offends you it's because you're
a sad small human being okay really
first of all ask any dude if they'd be
offended if a girl called them
sweetheart okay the answer is no if a
girl called the dude sweetheart we'd be
like that's kind of Awesome
like it would be nice if women treated
us nicely on a daily basis that'd be
pretty spectacular so it just is
ridiculous from Ashley Judd but the
feminist movement is is Don Quixote in
search of a windmill and so they will
continue to vault at those windmills
okay so final final thing we are going
to do a quick quick quick
Bible review today so this is from
Isaiah chapter 50 so every week the Jews
read a portion of the Torah and then we
also read a portion from the prophets
and the writings misses this week's
portion does the Lord God open my ear I
did not rebel I did not turn away
backwards I gave my back to spiders and
my cheeks to them that plucked off the
hair I did not hide my face from
embarrassment and spinning but the Lord
God helps me therefore I was not
embarrassed therefore I made my face
like flint and I knew I would not be
ashamed
so it's interesting because this
obviously priests ages the the New
Testament section where talks about
turning the other cheek right I mean
this is pretty clear language where he
says that he turns his cheek to people
who plucked off his hair you know what
he's saying here is not the you not you
should not speak the truth that you
should give leeway to bad people who
harm you what he is saying is that you
should not feel spiritually insulted
when people say the wrong thing to you
should be strong enough in your values
and when people say things that are not
true about you you shouldn't
take it to heart you shouldn't be
embarrassed you should make your face
like flint you shouldn't accept the
criticism as meaning that you're a
lesser human being you should understand
that being tough in the name of God you
know being tough on behalf of
judeo-christian values these things are
should give you strength it should give
you the inner strength to know that if
people slap you okay so whatever they
slap you a big deal big deal you're
stronger than that your values are
stronger than that he whom indicates you
is near whoever wishes to quarrel with
you let us stand together whoever is my
contender shall approach me the Lord God
shall help me who is he that will
condemn me behold all of them shall wear
out less garment a moth shall consume
them and this is right people who
espouse the wrong values in life they do
tend to wear out pretty quickly and so
do those values as we are seeing every
day from the from the international hard
left okay so we will be back here
tomorrow hopefully there won't be a
nuclear war in the meantime that would
be unfortunate I would hate to - for the
world to end while I'm number two -
Oprah on iTunes now would just be sad so
let's make me number one on iTunes and
then if there's nuclear war I think we
all can can live with that end of the
world I think we can okay i'm ben
shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]